hi I'm Eric Voss and this is a breakdown
of brick and mortar Season three Episode
six rest in Rick lack sation this was
such an enjoyable classic episode of
Rick and Morty and I'm gonna dig into
all these specific reasons that make it
great
subtle jokes in the animation what this
episode is saying about Rick and Morty
as human beings and yeah the dark
messed-up [ __ ] we all loved and real
quick because we can't make all these
videos for free guys this video was
sponsored by our friends at quid quid is
an app that allows you to drag and drop
stickers on to text message threads
including Rick and Morty themed ones
they also have Rick and Morty themed
Funko pop figures and we're gonna do a
giveaway for those I'll get to those
details later yeah sound good even up a
bastard it's cool let's just jump into
this episode so these opening images
condense an entire Rick and Morty
adventure into a couple minutes and then
the story shows us something we almost
never see their immediate vulnerable
emotional response to the stress of this
adventure maybe it's just me but this
has reminded me a lot of that real fake
doors commercial in rixty minutes like
you expect it to be over but then we
awkwardly follow the people back to
their cars to their real authentic lives
and then you realize oh wait this is all
part of it so why are we seeing this the
show uses this introspective detour to
set up a core theme attic question that
cuts to the heart of this series
what is toxic behavior exactly according
to Rick a person's toxic behavior is
whatever they hate the most about
themselves how could that Dee talk to
machine know the difference between
healthy and sick for everything that
goes through it it can't it must be by
the individual's own definition of
toxicity so in Morty's case his purely
toxic self is weak scared lacking
confidence and restrained by his own
self-hatred it is and it's your best
quality so true I mean while toxic rick
is narcissistic
I'm surrounded by inferior PC
emotionally abusive stupid Morty he has
a god complex if God exists it's me he's
a sexual deviant believe me I got a lot
more use out of that thing
he ever did and Rick's toxic world is
made out of snot because that was the
most recent toxic behavior that he
expressed guilt over try swallowing the
giant ball of snot that's dangling
around in the back of your throat
it's disgusting nobody wants to hear
that did you hear me bite that guy's
head off jeez I really need to chill but
it's healthy Rick discovers that toxic
rick is also capable of love a weakness
that he actually uses against his
bizarro self my entitlement my
narcissism my crippling loneliness my
irrational attachments so rick is
suggesting that love is a form of toxic
behavior this is actually something that
we've heard him bring up before back in
the first season
listen Morty I hate to break it to you
but what people call love is just a
chemical reaction that compels animals
to breed it hits hard Morty then it
slowly fades leaving you stranded in a
failing marriage I did it your parents
are gonna do it
break the cycle Morty rise above focus
on science but then Rick also concedes
that love is an essential toxin as this
episode progresses healthy Morty and
healthy Rick are monsters of a different
kind
like sure healthy Rick is kinder and
more optimistic and he wears a seat belt
for the first time ever but he's also
fully capable of killing Morty normally
protecting Morty is Rick's one morally
redeeming quality and yeah healthy Morty
is the worst he is the embodiment of all
the obnoxious tendencies of detox bros
who think they have all the answers but
are actually psychopathic like it's
totally one-dimensional and he speaks in
these lame jokes but I have a pretty bad
case of haven't taken you to dinner itis
might be fatal he also dominates
conversations without truly listening so
excited to finally have dinner with you
you know how long I've been waiting for
this it's like oh I I wish you'd shut up
though just kidding you know you're so
quiet what's wrong
what are you tell me about yourself
what's the atmosphere like on planet
Jessica where's the equator what are the
indications and the in the holidays I
mean you know are they the same time
talk to me he also quotes meaningless
pop songs as if they're profound life is
a highway and then he does that thing
where he like severs his relationship to
technology downgrading to a flip phone
like he's better than everyone else but
then hypocritically returns to a
smartphone just a few weeks later so
really Morty needs his insecurities
they're a core element to his identity
and without them we hate him as a person
so returning to that big question what
is toxic behavior well according to this
episode toxic behavior is what makes us
human it's the monster inside us that we
obviously can't let take over completely
but a monster that we need to maintain a
balance okay let's actually jump back to
this scene at the top of the episode you
may have noticed that it's almost a
shot-for-shot repeat of a past episode
opening Ric potion number 9 so this
whole episode is structured kind of like
a thematic sequel to that episode the
way that the Vindicator episode was a
sequel to the meeseeks and destroy'
episode so let's actually get into all
the ways that this episode connects to
past episodes with our segment call back
and let's start by talking about the
other parallels to Ric potion number 9
both episodes center around Morty's
crush on Jessica and both episodes he
gets close to getting the girl but then
he realizes it's not exactly what he
imagined it would be both episodes bring
up Jessica's boyfriend Brad actually
when healthy Morty randomly catches the
football and throws it back I feel like
that could be a reference to Brad's
stupid ass selling point in the previous
episodes actual ball spa and of course
both episodes feature the whole world
being transformed into a toxic nightmare
healthy Rick even kind of alludes to the
last time it's not our place you know to
pick and choose which world gets saved
from what apocalypse okay there are also
a few past one-off characters who make
cameos this episode there's father Bob
the phoney priest from get schwifty and
then in this episode one of Jessica's
friends is Trisha she's the girl who
stole summers boyfriend Ethan last
episode they're also some background
characters who pop up again like that
veiny headed guy and summers old band
friend Nancy now last episode we learned
that brick has these cybernetic implants
like Inspector Gadget and by the way the
reason he has those might be because
remember back in the season premiere he
swapped his consciousness into a new
Rick but in this episode the growing
system 6000 might be an example of
another type of cybernetic part that's
in his belt buckle actually I think that
could be a reference to the belt buckle
gun that's in the movie from dusk till
dawn and now that healthy Rick has used
this DNA dart to implant his own DNA and
incubate inside toxic Rick bursting out
into this new clone of himself I'm
guessing that he doesn't have those
cybernetic implants anymore
Andy's
back to normal I think my favorite
callback this episode was the show that
summer is watching on TV the days and
nights of mrs. pancakes remember that's
the soap opera that mr. goldenfold and
Rick Love is in truce in the second
episode episode that summers watching
here looks like it could be part of the
same episode okay moving on this whole
opening adventure that Rick and Morty go
on probably seemed a bit familiar to you
there's a plasma shard in the Abaddonn
go cluster a princess has it if I get it
I'll be awesome yeah this is the basic
plot of Star Wars where the old man and
the kid go off to rescue the princess
let's actually explore all of the pop
culture influences on this episode in
this segment that we call under the
influence
so following through with this Star Wars
influence the interior of this
mothership that Rick and Morty destroyed
looks like the interior of the second
Death Star from Return of the Jedi
also this victory ceremony is a pretty
clear homage to the rebellion ceremony
at the end of a new hope and this whole
premise of Rick and Morty having to
fight their toxic selves is a pretty
common premise in sci-fi fantasy in
comics there of course is the character
bizarro the toxic form of Superman there
are also versions of the Hulk and venom
comics where the two competing
identities have to clash with each other
actually speaking of venom the way that
Morty annoyingly struts down the hallway
pointing that girl's yeah this is a
pretty clear nod to emo Peter Parker in
spider-man 3 there's even this bit with
the jazz music with Morty doing this
stupid spin and flip and slide just like
Peter does in the jazz club and there's
a couple other sci-fi influences on this
episode that i cought healthy Rick
receives this creepy transmission on his
phone from the toxic world this is also
a common sci-fi trope specifically it
could be a reference to stranger things
where characters receive these staticky
haunting messages on their phones and
radios from the upside down dimension
which yeah has a similar appearance to
the toxic world and then the DNA dart
that the Rick's used to incubate
themselves in these new bodies and
bursts out of them could be based on the
xenomorph technology from the alien
movies notice how this new Rick cloned
into an adult version super rapidly just
like this anymore Stu
now I also really love this visual joke
of the toxic versions of the people in
Saladworks running over to borrows and
then the person Sbarro's running out to
eat out of a dumpster feel like actually
it could be a nod to that great Simpsons
gag remember when the churchgoers and
the patrons at Moe's swap places when
the apocalypse arrives
now when healthy morty becomes this
douchey stockbroker there's actually a
few iconic Wall Street Bros that are
influencing this persona notice his
speech when he closes the deal this is a
pretty parallel scene to Leo DiCaprio
sleazy sale in the wolf of Wall Street I
also like how Morty uses his past
fawning over Jessica as a metaphor in
this new sales pitch this stock is a
beautiful redhead recently single now
looking a date but ready to fall in love
and fate has put her Locker to down from
years to Wayne to lockers down actually
during dinner with Jessica earlier Morty
drums the table a lot like how
McConaughey does in the wolf of Wall
Street and he answers the phone the same
way Barney Stinson and Neil Patrick
Harris does in How I Met Your Mother
go from Morty and then Rick says this
line of Morty
sorry treaty American Psycho that of
course is a reference to the Christian
Bale film American Psycho and yeah the
character of Patrick Bateman is
definitely influencing Morty here
there's also a quick reference to the
matrix blue pill or red pill
what will it be bro and then Rick has
these awesome drones that assemble into
a small Voltron robot I love it they
even included the sound effects you keep
keep the drums now there's one more
pop-culture reference that I really love
from this episode but before I get to
that I want to take a quick moment here
because again guys we can't just do
these videos for free so big things two
quid for sponsoring it quid is an
awesome new app where you can collect
cool stickers cards and Funko pop
figures for free all on your phone from
hot shows like bee just release Game of
Thrones Rick and Morty Steven universe
Bob's Burgers Powerpuff Girls and Family
Guy cult hits like Breaking Bad and Star
Trek and from games like five nights at
Freddy's and fallout you can drag and
drop these stickers in iMessage and if
you collect Funko pop stickers yeah quit
has those too actually we're gonna do a
giveaway if you follow us on twitter and
then share this video on twitter with
the hashtag new rick stars we will pick
a couple of you at random and send you
free Funko pop rick and morty figures
now some of these stickers cards and
toys are super rare so good luck but the
good news is is that you can meet cool
people and quinn look at their
collections and trade with them just as
easily and quickly as chatting with each
other and in a new feature you can
showcase your collection by adding
stickers to pictures that you already
have in your camera roll see the profile
tab on iOS new stickers cards and
figurines are released every day
including a surprise big new show coming
soon so yeah definitely get on that okay
back to one of my favorite details in
this episode there's a little Easter Egg
hidden in this toxic world we can just
barely make out this guy
this is 8-ball a character from the
series gravity falls he was part of an
evil crew from another dimension who
tried to take over gravity falls in the
weirdmageddon storyline before getting
banished to another unknown dimension
now perhaps Rick came across 8-ball at
some point like storing him as a toxic
memory that ended up in this toxic world
now gravity falls is created by alex
hirsch who's a friend of justin roiland
the two have actually reference to each
other shows in the past and there's a
theory that rick and morty and gravity
falls are just
parallel dimensions within the same
animated universe remember in the season
premiere there were cameos by Mabel and
dipper Morty's in the citadel also there
was that Easter egg from closer it
counters of the Rik kind when a few
random objects flew out of the portal
those were grunkle Stan's mug and
notepad that got sucked into a portal in
gravity falls okay moving on I'm gonna
make a quick aside here to point out the
darkest moment of this episode so last
episode the darkest moment was obviously
when the alien kid shot his sister when
the immortality field was down and the
darkest moment of this episode also
featured extreme violence around kids
when the toxic beam wears off really the
people who were most harmed by this was
a group of kids at a birthday party
notice how they severed the head this
girl has a bat with silver we're hearing
that she's swinging around and blood is
everywhere even filling up the swimming
pool okay moving on again as usual this
episode was packed with subversive
sexual humor some obvious some a little
more sneaky seems like the creator's
love to hide these throughout episodes
kind of like Hidden Mickeys and Disney
properties so taking some inspiration
from the Hidden Mickey search let's run
down all these in Rick and Morty with
that segment we're calling
hidden Dicky so in the first line of the
episode Trish's banter in the background
it's pretty gross she would've loved to
shoot that docking kind of love yeah
like penis in the foreskin kind of love
just like warm so yeah docking is a
sexual term and I'm not gonna tell you
to look it up just know that what Tricia
just described is exactly what it is and
then the last line of the episode is a
direct call back to this moment and
Tricia gets way grosser have you ever
been peed on before oh my god YUM I
actually feel like both of these gross
moments are a callback to that joke in
rixie business remember when Tammy was
having a similar x-rated conversation at
the party I love watching [ __ ] I mean
I don't know if I personally would ever
do it I guess [ __ ] again maybe not
something you need to google and not
topics that teenage girls need to be
discussing and that also goes for the
other foreign sex term that Morty brings
up later hey Rick are you familiar with
Benoit technology Morty is referencing
Benoit balls now I can't show you
exactly how the
just know that they roll around and go
into things and yeah we're just gonna
look over the fact that Stacy and
Jacqueline are both grown women in
sexual relationships with an underage
boy another hidden deke sort of here
he's pursuing enemy ships from the
opening adventure are clearly designed
to look like sperm cells and you listen
closely to these church shots when the
toxic beam spreads over them and the
orgy begins justin roiland whispered
some dirty talk and mix it in the audio
lastly listen to this random shuffle
song that Morty plays on the radio this
actually reminded me a lot of the
nonsense lyrics of get schwifty but we
actually hear a longer version of the
song over the closing credits and it
starts to get super sexual you can grab
my holy folds squeeze on tight you son
of a [ __ ] my terry flaps in your mouth
you piece of [ __ ] okay let's um cleanse
the palate with a few other fun details
that I noticed in this episode first
notice this exchange between the Rick's
come on man I've been trapped in your
[ __ ] brain for 70 years of delusions
this is actually the first time we've
gotten a range of Rick's age he is now
clearly in his 70s also if you're
looking at the background shelves of
this episode there's a few fun animation
details so let's see if we can find
those with zooming enhance in the living
room if you look closely at the framed
family photos Beth has taped a horse
head over Jerry's face so just like last
episode Beth is using her day job as a
horse surgeon to distract from her
divorce and then zooming and enhancing
in Morty's fancy New York flat there's a
framed cover of GQ magazine with Morty
on the cover then after this great post
credit scene where Stacy finally gets
freed from the toxic world on the top of
this moon tower there was this
interesting controversy that came up in
the moments after the episode Adult Swim
aired a commercial break bumper that
read the writing on Game of Thrones 2011
to 2016 ooh burn yeah some people were
reading this as the show Rick and Morty
dissing the writing on the past season
of Game of Thrones but to be clear
Justin roiland and the show's Twitter
accounts both confirmed this was not
written by their staff this came from
someone who were
for the Adult Swim Network Merlin
actually says it's a big fan of Game of
Thrones he and I actually heard a rumor
that he secretly recorded a voice cameo
that was featured in one of the past
episodes of Game of Thrones this season
I have actually been scouring the audio
of every Game of Thrones episode this
season
day and night and no luck yet but I have
hope that all here mister poopy butthole
screaming during the dragon battle or
appear the faintest mr. meeseeks we
during the frozen lake battle anyway
please viewers help me find this I will
not sleep until I find it now to me
healthy bro Morty has been one of the
funniest incarnations of the character
but I'd like to know from you which
Morty has been your favorite remember
we've also seen Morty's like lawyer
Morty or Android Morty evil Morty
there's also this really fun pseudo form
of mourning that I refer to as rage
Morty like when he violently snapped in
look who's purging now sound off on your
favorites below in the comments you can
also tweet me directly at Eva's or new
rock stars at new rock stars and
remember share this video with the
hashtag new Rick stars so that you can
be eligible for that Funko pop giveaway
and subscribe to this channel and check
out all of our past breakdowns of Rick
and Morty season 3 next week actually
won't have a new episode so we'll keep
an eye out the following week for our
breakdown of episode 7 the Rick lantus
mix-up and if you want to help us make
more videos and reduce our dependency on
other ways we have to make money you can
always contribute on a monthly level to
new rock stars on patreon big thanks to
all of our current donors we love you
guys especially Kenny Smith all right
thanks for watching bye